D, I suppose I should talk about this Eminem thing. I forgot and logic thing.
I forgot to talk about this last week,
the video came out and every time the video comes out or I
get something big like that, I always text Brian Callan and will Sasso.
It's different. Now I always send, I always say, Hey, it's different now.
Or I'll go off state of Brian Callan. One time I was in an elevator,
I told him I got some big news. It was them. And I'm thinking whatever I say,
I'm going to be an M and M's video.
And then I just looked at him and I go like this right into his face cycle by
like, I'll never hang out with him again. I'm not even 40 though.
I can get away with that. I'm so young. God it. I'm so young.
There was no one younger. Um, so, so I.
Go by really obnoxious.
To his face. So, but yeah. Um, was I talking about the Eminem thing? Yeah. So,
uh, so yeah, so here's how it went down.
Cause I know people are asking because I see it.
So I did the impression Eminem obviously tweeted about it and then
logic and Eminem did a song logic put, uh,
m&m wanted to put me on the end of it. They called my manager, my manager said,
oh, okay. And so then I let them have it.
And then he's like, well, Monica wants to call you. Okay, isn't calling.
And so logic called me, talked to logic.
Logic's a nicest guy I ever met in my life over the phone. Uh, we talked, we,
uh, and then he was like, I got an idea for the video.
I think maybe it'd be cool video if like you did the m&ms part. And I was like,
you know, of course I'll do it. So then I
showed up on the set and they showed me M and M's impression of me.
They had already shot it in Detroit or some.
And it was unbelievable to see M and M dressed in a wig of
that would look like mine. And he was doing,
of course when it was informal and a bonus and a phone.
And I couldn't believe my eyes and they put my wig on.
And then I wrapped M and M's part,
it took about five hours and then I did it.
And then it came out like three weeks later.
And my life's different now.
Um, what, what would DJ, uh, my price just went up.
What would he say? What would that guy say? Uh, uh,
not my price. What would he say?
I ma.
My price just went up, I think, was that what he would say?
I don't know whatever he said though. You know, still in the meeting.
My price went up, my price just went up.
Uh, it's the best DJ Kelly. Do, you know?
It's so funny that somebody could get so famous that everyone has to recognize
them. No matter what,
like I see like DJ Khalid in like videos with mark Walberg and I'm like, mark,
Walberg.
What the are you doing? You.
Know,
like you're a real actor and you're really good and cool and a
family man and killing it. And you got Wahlburgers.
What the are you doing?
Associating with a guy who's still in the meeting.
I'm still in the meeting. Somebody gets,
that's the thing that's the goal is to get that famous to where you could just
do, like be on a jet ski and be like, my price just went up.
And still half, half to have like.
A legit, a list actor be like, all right, well, if I'm in a video with him,
I guess I'll get with the kids. I'll get the kids. They'll be,
I'll be popping with the kids. I mean,
DJ Khaled is basically, Tech-Talk still in the meeting.
And then when DJ Kayla did the lat workouts, bro, I almost fainted. He did,
he was doing it so bad. Um, but yeah,
I don't know. I guess you got to, I guess if I was here we go,
DJ Collins, hitting the weights. Look, this is the best. Oh,
it's three minutes of it. Jesus Christ.
He just, I, I want to meet DJ Kappa. He's a he's. He's probably a nice guy,
right. He probably busted nuts so quick. It's unbelievable.
Like he's never had a orgasm longer than half a second. Like he'll just be like,
yeah, yeah, yeah. And then just, and that's it.
And then he just rolls over because he's a quickest sleeper after an orgasm.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
And that's it. And that's it like a lion, you know how they do it real quick
and it goes, my price just went up. I can't,
I can't not make him sound like LL cool.
J I don't remember what the DJ Khaled sounds like.
Um, but yeah, just,
uh, whatever, you know, what DJ,
God, I, what is he worth? What's DJ caliber. This never right,
but what's his net worth.
Yeah. $35 million. I would think it'd be more than that.
The guy produces everything. It probably is that always wrong.
I think on mine it says mine's like $400 million and I'm like, okay,
well when can I see that? So yeah, the Eminem thing was cool.
I got to do that. It's actually awesome.
I re I watched clips of the video for the first two days.
And then I was like, wait, I never actually watched the video.
And then I watched it on the second, uh, on like the third day.
And I was like, Jesus Christ. It kind of gave me chills. I was like, dude,
this is incredible. Actually like when I was nine,
18 Eminem came out on the scene and I was like, whoa, this guy's amazing.
And he was like one of my favorite rappers.
And now I'm in a video and not only am I playing him, he's playing me.
It was just really incredible.
Those moments are few and far in between in your life. But, um,
that was one of them.
And I'm very grateful for it. I really am.
So that's what.